I'M GETTING TOO (ADJECTIVE)
FOR THIS (NOUN).
YOU KNOW, MAYBE BECAUSE I'M
GETTING OLDER MYSELF BECAUSE
WE ALL ARE, 'CAUSE TIME MOVES IN
ONE DIRECTION, AND WE CAN'T
STOP IT, AND OUR DEATH IS
HANGING OUT THERE IN THE
BALANCE SOMEWHERE EVER WAITING
TO POUNCE ON US SOME DAY WHEN
WE LEAST EXPECT IT, BUT WE
TOTALLY BLANKED ON AN
IMPORTANT ANNIVERSARY LAST
WEEK.
WE FORGOT TO WISH ACTOR
DANNY GLOVER A HAPPY 69th
BIRTHDAY.
HAPPY 69th BIRTHDAY.
HE'S FINALLY TOO OLD FOR
THIS [BLEEP].
AND I GUESS I'M TOO OLD FOR
THIS [BLEEP] TOO BECAUSE I
FORGOT ABOUT IT SO IN HONOR OF
DANNY GLOVER
AND THAT ICONIC LAMENTATION, I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT YOU ARE GETTING
TOO SOMETHING FOR SOMETHING.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
JESSE.
>> I'M GETTING TOO RACIST
FOR THIS WRESTLING
FEDERATION.
>> POINTS.
>> JAMIE.
>> I'M GETTING TOO HORNY FOR
THIS FUNERAL.
>> POINTS.
>> JORDAN.
>> I'M GETTING TOO ARBY'S
ROAST BEEF SANDWICHES FOR
THE PRICE OF ONE.
>> POINTS.
>> I'M GETTING TOO VIOLENT
FOR THIS MARRIAGE TO TINA
TURNER.
>> OH, [BLEEP].
>> JORDAN.
>> I'M GETTING TOO FAST FOR
THIS FURIOUS 7.
>> I'M GETTING TOO STUBBORN
AND CLOSE TO DEATH TO
COME CLEAN ON THESE RAPE
ALLEGATIONS.
>> POINTS.
>> JAMIE.
>> I'M GETTING TOO EMOTIONAL
FOR THIS GANGBANG.
>> POINTS.